wo ist ein
[Musik]
also herr fischer ich habe noch 50
andere bewerber warum sollte ich sie
einstellen
was sind ihre stärken ich bin
zuverlässig ich würde gern in ihrem
unternehmen arbeiten sind sie teamfähig
tschuldigung konnten sie das bitte
wiederholen können sie gut im team
arbeiten ja ich habe ihn so denn immer
im team gearbeitet was haben sie dort
gemacht
ich bin arzt dann haben sie auch eine
spezialisierung oder biologe haben sie
erfahrung im schichtdienst natürlich
aber ich würde gern nachmittags und
abends arbeiten weil ich vormittags noch
einen sprachkurs besuchen
das ist kein problem wollen sie teilzeit
oder vollzeit arbeiten
ich möchte vollzeit arbeiten
[Musik]
ich sehe sie montag um 14 uhr am
arbeitsplatz dann klären wir alles was
bedeutet dass sie haben den job erst
einmal befristet auf drei monate
willkommen im team herrsche
gut gemacht das wird schon